病院に自分以外に若い人が一人もいないと気付いたとき財布をなくしていることに
気づく前に
他人から財布を返された時電源の入った fax の前に立った時ゴジラが現れたとき
か人が先にどうぞと車のライトを照らした時位の子供のバックパックに
に7万円を費やした時当日予約して受けたいんまぁ雷が3500円しかしなかった時
こんだけこうなっているバイクシート見たとき道でばったり口の避けた女に出会った時
レストランで小さすぎる水が運ばれてきたとき何これ適当に頼んだらめちゃくちゃ
美味しい料理が
コバれてきた時外国人であるだけで英語ができると思われた時
覚えてテレビ番組の司会者が掲示板から大きなシールを剥がしたときそれではいきます
よ自信満々ゲームセンターの格闘コーナーに生えたら
技を一つも決めずに泣きながら帰ったとき入学したらあんま
あり勉強しない学校に入学するためにもう一つの学校に入学して勉強しだした時ラボ本
に行ったとき電車で知らないおじさんが自分の型を枕として使ったときちょっと大きて
月もうサロンの広告が流れた時
メンズの足の毛の自分が悪いことを全くしていないのに
おのずからすいませんねといった時来年からまた消費税がかかると言われた時映画の
エンドロールが始まっても誰も席から立とうとしない時向こうではなく
こうやって文字打ったとき校ではなく
こうやってドアを開けたとライブでコーデをなくこうやったとき地震速報でプチ心臓
発作を起こされ
医者でない人に血液型を聞かれたとき日本語上手
と言われたくてえんぬ1の文法を無理やり会話の中で使おうとする外国人見たときで
から英語ができると思われたくて
とにかく下品な言葉を連発する日本人を見たときないばくらい給料の低いマン氏の総持
院が勤勉に働いているのを見たとき焼肉屋さんで最後の一口を誰も取ろうとしないとき
どと現金のみと言われた時エビバーガーという言葉を口にしたとき喋っていないのに
シャベル能力を褒められた時気が登った時
me